[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
MORE THAN 3.5 MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN LIFTED OFF OF FOOD
STAMPS.
>> Janine: THAT WAS
DONALD TRUMP LAST NIGHT IN
PENNSYLVANIA TOUTING HIS
ECONOMIC SUCCESSES.
AND IT TODAY, NEW ECONOMIC
NUMBERS REVEAL THE ECONOMY IS
BOOMING.
JUST LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
STATISTICS.
157,000 JOBS WERE ADDED IN JULY
AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
DOWN TO 3.9%.
HISPANIC ON EMPLOYMENT HAD A NEW
RECORD LOW IN JULY.
EARLIER TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETED A ABOUT THE GREAT
ECONOMIC NEWS, WRITING "JULY IS
4%.
OUR ECONOMY HAS ADDED MILLIONS
OF JOBS SINCE I WON THE
ELECTION.
MORE THAN 4 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
RECEIVED A PAY RAISE DUE TO TAX
REFORM.
$400 BILLION BROUGHT BACK FROM
OVERSEAS.
OF COURSE, THE LEFT IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SPIN THE IS A
GREAT ECONOMIC NUMBERS FOR TRUMP
"LOSING THEIR JOBS."
JOINING US NOW IS THE AUTHOR OF
"WHY WE FIGHT."
FOX NEWS SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GORKA AND AUSTIN GOLD
TO BE.
I WANT TO GO TO YOUR FIRST.
SO YOU REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID TO
THE INNER-CITY, AND NOW
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT IS
THE LOWEST IN HISTORY.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO SAY THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT A GOOD
PRESIDENT AT LEAST IN THIS
ECONOMY?
>> I'M KIND OF SURPRISED THAT
YOU ARE CHOOSING TODAY'S JOB
NUMBER BECAUSE TODAY'S JOB
NUMBER IS ALMOST 40,000 BELOW
WHAT WAS EXPECTED.
>> Janine: THAT'S
EXPECTATIONS, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S NOT A PLUS.
>> 150,000 IS OKAY.
IN THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE PROUD
OF THAT NUMBER.
>> Janine: OKAY AUSTIN, I KNOW
YOU HAVE A TOUGH JOB TONIGHT BUT
YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER YOU.
BOARD, I GET IT.
BUT LET'S GET BACK INTO THE REAL
WORLD.
I READ YOUR BOOK AND YOU KNOW
THE PRESIDENT, HE WANTS SUCCESS
FOR ALL AMERICANS AND THIS IS
WHAT THE LEFT DOESN'T GET IT.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T CARE IF YOU
VOTED FOR HIM OR NOT.
YOU COULD HAVE WANTED BERNIE TO
BE PRESIDENT OR YOU MAY HAVE
VOTED FOR HILLARY, BUT HE WANTS
YOU TO SUCCEED.
HE WANTS YOU TO BE SAFE AND HE
WANTS YOU TO PROSPER.
THAT'S A PRESIDENT.
AND THE LEFT WILL NEVER BELIEVE
IT.
>> Janine: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
AUSTIN, WHEN THE DEMOCRATS START
RUNNING, AND THEY ARE RUNNING
NOW WHICH IS WHY THE PRESIDENT
HAS ALREADY STARTED THIS PUSH.
DO THEY JUST IGNORE THE ECONOMY,
POOR DO THEY TALK ABOUT MAYBE
ISIS COMING BACK?
WHAT DO THEY SAY?
>> I THINK WHAT THEY WOULD SAY
IS THE NUMBERS YOU'VE QUOTED
WHERE YOU SAY MORE THAN
4 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN A
RAISE.
AS 150 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK AT JOB CREATION
RATES OR WAGE GROWTH, BOTH OF
THOSE HAVE ACTUALLY SLOWED DOWN
IN THE 18 MONTHS THAT WE'VE BEEN
UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
SO I THINK THEY WILL PROBABLY
HIGHLIGHT THOSE FACTS.
>> Janine: AND DO YOU THINK
THAT AMERICA -- I'M GOING TO LET
SEBASTIAN ANSWER THAT.
DO YOU THINK AMERICA ACTUALLY
AGREES WITH NANCY ABOUT, IT'S
JUST PROBLEMS.
WOULD THEY RATHER NOT SEE EXTRA
MONEY IN THEIR PAYCHECKS?
>> AFTER YOU COME AUSTIN.
THE ONE I THOUGHT YOU -- >> I
THE ECONOMY IS THE LOWEST THAT
IT'S EVER BEEN.
>> TRUMP SHOULD EMPHASIZE THAT
UP.
>> SO WHAT SHOULD AUSTIN AND HIS
CADRE SAY TO THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE THE LOWEST MINORITY
UNEMPLOYMENT SINCE
RECORD-KEEPING BEGAN?
YOU CAN'T SPIN THAT.
YOU CAN'T SAY, THE GROWTH HAS
DECELERATED.
WHO CARES.
WE HAVE OIL COMPANIES THAT ARE
GIVING $25,000 SIGNING BONUSES
IN AMERICA AND THAT IS AN
ECONOMY UNLEASHED.
WE HAVE BASICALLY FICTIONAL ZERO
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE MORE JOBS AVAILABLE AND
PRIVATE SECTOR JOBS, THE LONGEST
STREAK EVER.
ABOUT 18 OF THOSE MONTHS WERE
UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND THE REST
WERE UNDER BARACK OBAMA.
AND IT'S GREAT, I'M TOTALLY FOR
GDP GROWTH.
>> Janine: SAY THAT AGAIN
AUSTIN?
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING WE DON'T
HAVE -- >> A GROWTH RATE OF 3%.
>> SO FOR ONE QUARTER -- IT
HAPPENED FOUR DIFFERENT TIMES.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
BARACK OBAMA HAD US CONVINCED
THAT 1% GDP WAS THE NEW NORMAL.
THOSE BOZOS ACTUALLY BELIEVED
THAT WE ARE NOW AT 4.1.
>> I BELIEVE THAT'S NOT CORRECT.